Okay. So, go ahead. Yeah.
>> Yeah. Uh, I had a question about uh
>> not live in yourself. Let's just put it
this way. Uh,
>> you can say dead here on on uh
>> I I don't know what I can say. So, I'm
just
>> Yes, here it's on Tik Tok. You can't say
that. That's why Tik Tok sucks.
>> Anyways, um like there's a
>> people say that if you unal alive
yourself that you'll go to hell. I just
said you can say suicide brother.
>> Oh yeah suicide. So if you if you commit
suicide that you'll go to hell which is
not true. I watched your videos and you
said that the only thing God that
doesn't doesn't forgive is blasphe.
Yeah.
>> But then my would be in 1 Corinthians 3
verse 16-1 17. Uh what does word destroy
mean then?
That's because someone is blasphing the
Holy Spirit. So what do you do when you
defile the temple? You're defiling the
spirit, right?
>> Yes.
>> So that would be blasphemy of the Holy
Spirit, right?
>> Yes, sir.
>> All right. So now you're asking me a
question that you're a Protestant. So
once in Protestant, you're in no man's
land. In other words, it's just you and
the Bible and how you interpret it.
>> Mhm.
>> So how do you want me to answer this?
Because if uh you ask me suicide is it
the unforgivable sin? The only
unforgivable sin is blaspheing the Holy
Spirit. That's the only sin Jesus said
will not be forgiven. But if someone
says, "Well, when you commit suicide,
you don't have time to repent." Well, if
you believe like Catholics do and others
that there is a chance in the
post-mortem state to be forgiven like
the case of the Jews in the war against
Antiochus and second Mcabes 1239
to 46 some versions is 1239-4
who were fighting to reclaim the temple
but because they had
idols of Gemini God struck them dead and
killed them dead.
Judas then offered prayers for them and
sacrifices with the hopes that though
they died committing idolatry, which is
a mortal sin, seeing their intention was
to fight for the glory of God, restore
the temple, that God would then forgive
them in the post-mortem state. So at the
resurrection, he'd reward them with
immortality. There are too many factors
and it's too difficult to give a
straight yes and no answer. Mhm.
>> Is why even in the Catholic church from
my understanding and orthodox church
they now take into consideration that
some suicides
may be because of serious psychosis
maybe because of some brain defect,
chemical malfunction in the brain, some
serious psychological impairment
>> or the person wasn't in his full int
intellectual
properties wasn't functioning in his
full intellectual capacity. So they take
that into consideration and leave it to
God.
>> So right so it's not a simple yes no
answer because the only sin that won't
be forgiven is blasphemy of the Holy
Spirit. So when you commit a mortal sin
that's because you blasphemy the Holy
Spirit.
That's why it's called the mortal sin
because to spiritually die means you cut
yourself off from the spirit, the source
of life. That would be blaspheing the
Holy Spirit. So now the question is, can
someone be restored? Obviously, Orthodox
Catholic churches believe you can be
restored. Otherwise, they would say
there's no hope for you if you commit a
mortal sin. Right.
>> Yeah.
>> So, it's very complex. It's too complex
for me to answer yes or no. When I was a
Bible only Christian, I could have been
more clear in my answer
if I just followed the Bible. If I was a
Bible only Christian. But since I don't
just go with how I understand the Bible,
I have to be careful of how I understand
the Bible because I have to look in into
the Bible in the context of the church
and the ancient teachings of the
Christians. And from what I gather,
Catholics, you can help me on this one.
The Catholic Church now takes into
consideration the psychological state of
the person who commits suicide. Was he
in his right frame of mind, operating
in his full intellectual capacities, or
was he hindered by something so that
he's not completely culpable for that
act?
too many
variables,
too many angles to look at it from for
me to give a definitive answer. I don't
know.
>> Yeah, I guess I have one more question
on this uh on this topic. Um in 1
Corinthians 3:16, it says, "Do you not
know that you are God's temple and that
God's spirit dwells in you?" And then on
verse 17 it says, "If anyone destroys
God's temple, God will destroy him." So
I guess I am trying to understand what
does the word destroy mean there. Um
that's what I'm battling with there. Is
isn't it talking like in division in
church and
>> these divisions are the result of sin,
right?
>> Yes sir. and how and how uh each will
get like
his own reward
>> fleshly introducing
heretical teaching dividing the church
and other issues. In fact, did you is
the only verse in your Bible 1
Corinthians 3:16
is not 1 Corinthians 6:1 19 and 20 in
your Bible where it says again we are
the temple of God and God's spirit lives
in us and there how do you defile and
destroy the temple by sexual immorality
and other moral vices listed in 1
Corinthians 6:9-11 mister
>> yeah that makes sense uh but what does
the word
It's twofold. Destroying the church by
bringing in damnable inviting it or
destroying an individual member of the
church who's the temple of God or
destroying yourself.
>> So even when you say destroying the
temple, there are various ways you can
destroy the temple. One way is you
destroy the temple,
meaning the corporate body of believers,
by dividing them and misleading them
with false teaching. Or you can cause a
member of the temple who himself is a
temple of the spirit, right, to stumble
or you can destroy yourself being a
temple of God. So there are various ways
in which you destroy the temple. You
make it sound like it's very simple,
black and white.
Yeah, it's it's not definitely not.
>> What specifically do you need help with?
>> I guess that was the question is because
one one of my friends uh um one of my
friends friend committed suicide and he
was asking me about that and I had no
idea how to answer that question. So
>> Kyle Kyle in Hebrews 11 Samson is listed
in the hall of faith. Now you said you
had a friend that committed suicide and
then someone asked you what? Uh, my
friend's friend committed a suicide and
so that friend was asking me a question
about this and I I did not know how to
answer it. So that's why I'm asking you.
>> Well, you tell your friend there are too
many variables involved. Only God knows
the state and condition of your friend.
I can't answer that question.
>> Got it?
>> Yes. The only unforgivable sin is
blaspheing of the Holy Spirit. But there
are various ways in which you can
blasphe the Holy Spirit. Now the
question is there it says you're never
forgiven. Well then isn't mortal sin
being cut off by the spirit and doesn't
that mean in a way you blasphe spirit to
be cut off by the spirit? But then you
can be restored. So even then what does
it mean never forgiven?
M
>> as a person that's re reached a level of
reprobation,
that means they're so dead in sin, so
encrusted by their sin, their hearts so
hardened by sin, they hate God and the
things of God and do not care to turn
back to God. But someone that has
committed mortal sin, who's still being
convicted and is afraid and wants it
restored, obviously they haven't reached
that level because if they did, they
wouldn't care. You see, it's much more
complex. So, what does our Lord mean
it'll never be forgiven? Does it mean
because these people have reached that
level of repbribation, they could care
less about God and the spirit and Christ
and openly oppose Christ to the very end
and have no fear of him? Is he referring
to them? Not to those individuals who
once they realize what they've done and
the grat of their sin are convicted and
come to their knees showing they're not
cut off completely by the spirit. It's
very complex.
>> That makes sense. Thank you, Sam.
>> That's why you need more brilliant men
than I theologians who spent years on
this one subject. See, in theology, you
have people who specialize in specific
areas of theology or canon law. So, you
have people who will spend their entire
life on this issue. What is blasphemy of
the Holy Spirit? How does that tie in
with mortal sin? What about suicide?
Does that come under blasphemy the Holy
Spirit? If so, what happens? People
devote themselves just on that one area
and study everything they can find in
the Bible throughout church history. For
example, someone gave the example of
Samson. Didn't Samson commit suicide? It
depends on how you define suicide. Okay,
now guys, you want me to go a little
deeper because someone brought up the
issue of Samson.
Samson is listed in Hebrews 11 as a man
who made it. Let's go to Hebrews 11.
Hall of Faith.
Okay. Hall of Faith.
Right there. Hebrews 11.
And what more shall I say? For time will
fail me if I recount Gideon, Barack,
Samson, Jeff, as well as David and
Samuel in the kingdoms, who through
faith conquered kingdoms. So, he's
listed as an example of a man of faith
in spite of his moral imperfections.
Just like David, right? Who inherited
heaven?
Right.
You with me there, Anton?
>> Yes, sir.
>> But he committed suicide. Or did he?
Here's where it gets more complicated.
How does someone define suicide?
If you define suicide to include someone
going into the battlefield knowing that
he's going to die in doing so, but
realizing that his death will bring a
greater benefit saving others, then is
that really suicide or is that a
sacrifice?
So if I know if I rush into the
battlefield, I'm going to end up getting
killed. I know I'm going to die. So, I'm
virtually committing suicide. But this
is the only way to then stop others from
being killed. If I plunge in the
battlefield, take them down with me so
we all die but others get saved.
Is that suicide or do we call that a
sacrifice?
>> That's a sacrifice.
>> Sacrifice that you sacrifice your life
to save others in the process.
Right.
>> Yes, sir.
>> So, was Samson committing suicide
because he was miserable and depressed
and hated life and just ended it,
leaving a hole in the hearts of others
who will never recover because their
loved one committed suicide. Because the
real sin is not so much in the person
ending his life or her life. The real
sin is the damage, the pain you cause,
those you leave behind. Because whether
you realize it or not, the people who
suffer and never recover are your loved
ones who will continue living in misery,
depression, sadness over your suicide,
trying to make sense out of it, who will
never recover until they die. So the
real sin is the damage and harm you do
to others because of that act.